breaking news the vatican has just
declared that it still holds the same
views that it has for 2000 years
on sex and marriage which is absolutely
shocking
to mainstream media journalists who just
cannot wrap their minds around the fact
that the pope
is catholic secular liberalism is a
jealous god
i'm michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from
wiedergonger who says so you believe
everything is racist everyone yes so who
are you racist against wait what i meant
to say is yes this was
the tom cotton excoriation of biden
deputy ag nominee venita gupta because
when the left
says look everybody is this everybody is
bigoted everybody's awful what they
really mean is
everybody except for me when they say
everybody's got to follow the rules
everybody's got to wear the mask
everybody's got a
lock down everybody's got to do this
everybody's got to do that what they
really mean is everybody but me
because they're on the inside they're
part of the special
group of elites that has the secret
knowledge
and that knows what's best for everybody
they don't need to give in to
noble lies of our republic they don't
need to follow the rules meant for the
peasants
they they are just so special that's
that's the way it is
i feel very special because i'm
protected by ring so much happens at our
front doors that is one thing that for
sure has not changed these days
especially for me
because i've got my sweet little
screaming bundle of joy that means that
we're getting food delivered because
nobody wants to cook with a screaming
baby
that means we're getting some people are
sending gifts for the baby that's really
nice
and it means that in-laws are coming to
visit you know and maybe you're going to
open it
the door maybe you're not going gonna
open the door it depends who's out there
that's why you should check out ring
with ring whether you are in the office
maybe you're in your bedroom maybe
you're on a beach on the other side of
the world
you can see and speak to whoever is at
the door
from anywhere okay it really makes me
feel safe when i'm on the road and sweet
little elisa and little
little june are there they can know
who's on the other side of the door
before they open it it's great to give
out as a housewarming gift i do this to
my friends not just because i want to
give them a great product
but because it's not very expensive and
so i get credit for a good product i
don't have to pay a lot
right now get a special offer on the
ring welcome kid at ring.com knowles
comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
chime pro the perfect way to upgrade
your front door and start your ring
experience go to ring.com
knowles that's ring.com knowles go
check out ring today
people are shocked by this announcement
the vatican released a statement
it was on the question of same-sex
marriage you know over the past
i guess now what is it eight years or so
there has been a major
movement in the west to redefine
marriage from its historic definition
as the union of husbands and wives and
more specifically for most of the time
the union of one husband and one wife
two now uh monogamous unions so they
they've kept the monogamy part but got
rid of the sexual difference part
and people at the time on the left were
arguing that this was a matter of rights
and people on the the right were failing
to argue but we're trying to argue at
least
that this was not a matter of rights
this was a question of what marriage
is it for all of human history
everywhere on earth marriage has had
something to do with sexual difference
now if you're radically going to
redefine that you're going to take away
the essential quality of marriage
for the essential social institution
maybe we should proceed with caution on
that
conservatives lost that battle in the
courts
and now though we were told at that time
that you know look
if you have a certain religious view
that's okay why does my gay marriage
have anything to do with your straight
marriage now
people are really shocked to find out
that the
catholic church the single most enduring
institution in our entire civilization
they're shocked to find out that they
still hold the same views that they
always have
on marriage don lemon went on the view
and chatted on this issue with megan
mccain
you got engaged to your fiancee tim in
2019
and this morning and you guys are so
cute we learned that the vatican has
said that the catholic church
won't bless same-sex unions quote since
god cannot bless sin
they go on to say that this does not
imply a judgment on persons
but i want to know do you think this
sends a damaging message and how do you
feel about that given that obviously
you are now engaged and going to get
married well i think
there are listen i respect people's
right to believe
in whatever they want to believe in
their god but if you believe in
something that
hurts another person that or that does
not give someone
the same rights or freedoms not
necessarily under the constitution
because this is
under god i think that that's wrong and
i think that the
the catholic church and many other
churches really need to re-examine
themselves and their teachings because
that is not what god
is about god is not about hindering
people or even judging people
i i love this because this is i i don't
even really care about the media shock
of uh regarding catholicism the media
are ignorant and arrogant and the
they vary in in that they vacillate in
between those two poles
but what i care about here is the
presumption don lemon says
i respect people's right to believe
in their religions but right and then
the but
immediately contradicts everything he
previously said because he says
i respect people's right to believe in
their religions but if it contradicts
my religion if it contradicts my view my
interpretation of people's rights and
freedoms and what people ought to be
able to do
if it in any way if other people's views
contradict my beliefs
then those beliefs ought to cut it out
then then those people need to ditch
those old beliefs
he's saying because if it contradicts my
rights well what is where do rights come
from
rights come from the law natural rights
come from the
natural law who gives us the natural law
god
all laws all rights have ultimately
come back to morality who gives us
morality a religious view of the world
so don lemon says sure you can believe
whatever you want just just don't
contradict me
and then he says after this whole look
man just don't come on we can all
believe what we want to believe you know
and just after all this
kind of dishonest hippy dippy rhetoric
he then says let me tell you what god
thinks
he then says the catholic church
bark of peter 2000 years
if you're catholic you believe
instituted by christ himself hands the
keys to the kingdom of heaven to saint
peter
the first pope who knows better
about what god thinks the catholic
church
or dawn freaking lemon catholic church
even if you don't believe i believe this
but let's say you don't believe this
that the catholic church
is divinely instituted surely it is the
case that an institute
an institution that has been devoted to
interpreting scripture
and developing theology for 2000 years
might have more sophisticated views on
the subject of what god thinks
than a cnn host named don lemon and we
know that this is true because don lemon
last year talking about a different
subject
made a little bit of a crucial
theological mistake
but here's the thing jesus christ if you
believe in if you if that's who you
believe in jesus christ
admittedly was not perfect when he was
here on this earth
so why are we deifying the founders of
this country
many of whom own slaves
jesus christ was admittedly he says
not perfect when he was on this earth so
he's not he's not
merely denying the divinity of christ
which is an
ancient ancient heresy it's one of the
earliest heresies in the church
he's also just making things up
about the the text of the gospels right
he's saying yeah admittedly you know
christ admitted this
i i would like to see that verse because
it's
pretty central to the whole
thing that christ is perfect
christ is blameless the sacrifice on the
cross
is perfect because christ is perfect
so all of that to say don lemon not the
most
educated in theology but he is very
presumptuous
he is frequently wrong but never in
doubt
i bring up this story not not so much
for the sexual aspect but for the
political aspect
because it's coming back to freedom and
rights and this very
liberal interpretation of freedom and
rights which now constitutes the secular
religion
i don't think that people are really
ignorant
of the the catholic church's teaching on
marriage
i don't think that while people are
clutching their pearls i don't think
it's out of ignorance i think the shock
is because they just assume
that eventually we're all going to ditch
our own beliefs
our old you know sturdy beliefs that
have endured for millennia
and we are going to adopt the new fetish
beliefs of secular liberal modernity
in a sane culture the shock would be
if the catholic church which has held
one view for 2 000 years
about a very crucial fundamental matter
just
completely changing it overnight that
would be shocking to a sane culture
but because we're now in an insane
culture the shock to us
is that they didn't change their views
overnight because
and you heard this in even in the way
don lemon spoke it gets back to
something that barack obama
used to use a lot of certain rhetorical
trick which is
we've we've gone from discussing freedom
of religion
in the practice of religion to freedom
of belief
is what don lemon's talking about or
freedom of worship
as barack obama says because
those phrases water down religion
freedom of worship what does that bring
up in your mind it means you get to go
to your church on sunday
and sing some songs and then leave right
and then go and then get back to
the business of liberal modernity okay
then you get back to secularism
monday through saturday then sunday you
can have freedom to worship freedom of
belief is just
you can have some ideas swimming in your
head you can't even really articulate
them
necessarily it's just freedom of belief
but freedom of religion is different
because religion is not just
a hobby religion is not just something
you compartmentalize
like we compartmentalize so much in
modernity religion
is everything and we all knew this
as a civilization until like five
minutes ago
our founding fathers understood this
they understood the religious
basis of government that's why they
invoke the creator
that's why they invoke god and the
natural rights given to us by god
in the declaration of independence
cardinal manning famously observed that
all human conflict ultimately is
theological
but because liberalism is such a jealous
god
many liberals they can't even wrap their
minds around that
that you wouldn't just ditch your the
enduring views that built our
civilization
and that edify the human soul and turn
turn our eyes up toward the heavens
that we wouldn't just ditch that for a
bunch of technocrats and lab coats
for a bunch of modern libs
taking power and telling us what to do
because they know the most efficient way
to run society
joe biden prime example of this right
joe biden devout catholic joe biden
was asked his view on the vatican's
perfectly anodyne statement that should
have surprised nobody
he he's upset about it on a different
subject the vatican
today said it would not bless same-sex
unions the presence of devout catholic
does he have a personal response
to that i don't think he has a personal
response
to the vatican no he continues to
believe
and support same-sex unions as you know
and he's long had that position
he's long had that position he's only
had that position since what was it
2012.
he's had that position for nine years
he's been in politics
for something like 50 years so even joe
biden who is the most radical president
we've ever had not because i think he
has particular ideological commitments
he's just a sort of weather vein he's an
empty vessel
for the democratic party establishment
which is moving further and further to
the left
but even even just by his own standard
for the vast
majority of his political career to say
nothing of the vast majority of his life
he has held the catholic view or at
least espoused
the catholic view but now because of the
acceleration of this cultural radicalism
even that absolutely anathema
joe biden has back before i was shaving
joe biden held these views and
joe biden i guess doesn't hold these
views anymore when i am shaving and i
when i shave you know
i shave with harry's razors it was a
little bit of a clunky segue but i'm
still gonna stick with it
harry's delivers a close comfortable
shave at a fair price
only two dollars per refill harry's
believes in quality so much
that they bought their own factory in
germany so that they could own
every step of the manufacturing process
how do they do it
very simple harry's team combined a
simple ergonomic design with five sharp
blades
they source their steel from sweden and
they manufacture their blades in their
world-class blade factory 100 quality
guarantee
they stand behind the quality of their
blades so much they have a 100 money
back guarantee
on harry's dot com for a limited time
harry's
has an exclusive offer for listeners of
my show
new customers can get a hairy starter
set and a free body wash
for just three dollars at harry's dot
com slash knowles that is over a
sixteen dollar value for just three
dollars you'll get a five blade razor
weighted handle foaming shave gel a
travel cover and a
travel size body wash it's an incredible
deal
but you gotta act fast while supplies
last head on over to harry's dot com
slash knowles to redeem your offer
this is the very razor that i use best
razor
i've ever used harrys.com knowles i
strongly recommend you go check out
harry's razors
so joe biden devout catholic at odds
with the catholic church on this
sort of fundamental issue of marriage
but he continues to call himself a
devout catholic because one of the tools
of political correctness which is you
know we use the term political
correctness or wokeness or whatever but
these are
these are just the instruments of
political leftism
joe biden believes that by changing
words
you can in some way change reality
that is one of the central conceit of
political correctness
and so forget about marriage right the
idea that you can just by changing the
words
you can change the reality of that thing
uh
down at the southern border joe biden is
facing
an historic crisis people flooding over
the border
we're seeing huge huge spikes kids in
cages the likes of which we never saw
under
president trump despite media coverage
to the contrary
despite the negative press covfefe so
joe and his team believe that by
by redefining what's going on at the
border they can redefine
the the reality of it jen saki was asked
about
this crisis down there ah she actually
don't want to call it that
mexico's president andres manuel lopez
obrador says the people coming into the
u.s right now
see biden president biden as the migrant
president does the white house take that
as a compliment
the migrant give me a little more
context well he said uh they see him as
the migrant president
and so many feel uh so many feel they're
going to reach the united states
we need to work together to regulate the
flow because this business can't be
tackled from one day to the next well
first it's
mexico will have to be is an important
partner in ensuring we're addressing
uh the flow of migrants from central
america
through mexico many to the border of the
united states
uh we have conveyed uh privately and
publicly as well that
the majority of people who come to our
border will be turned away
okay so still downplaying this i mean
the reporters have asked
they've been asking for weeks now will
you call it a crisis is it a crisis that
shoots you won't do it
now you've even got the president of
mexico
saying this this is biden's fault biden
is creating incentives
for people to be flowing to the border
and even that just downplaying it
no no you understand there are migrants
they're comp this is all perfectly
normal
they're they're fleeing their countries
they're going through mexico but they're
not staying in mexico because mexico is
not that nice
and america's really nice and you know
they're just seeking
safety from political persecution but
they want to seek the safety maybe more
up here where we have a strong economy
and a
stable government as a stable government
at least for now
the and so is he the migrant president
well what do you mean by migrant
president do you mean
well i don't know does the word mean
this what's actually happening
joe biden is creating incentives massive
incentives including a mass
amnesty plan for illegal aliens
and so you're getting more illegal
aliens
this is a central tactic to distract us
in these kind of semantic debates but
the problem is the words really
really do matter because they really do
color how we view these things
imagine imagine if this had been
president trump the kind of coverage
this would be getting but
by using that kind of anodyne language
oh well it depends you know
they just move right on another pc
tactic
is playing to people's basest
sexual passions this is where the the
sex issue does kind of
matter i mentioned earlier my interest
in the the story
my political interest in the catholic
story is
has more to do with our understanding of
freedom
and rights and liberal modernity but
my interest in whap my interest in the
grammys my interest in cardi b's
performance a couple nights ago
that actually does have to do with the
sexual aspect because
the left certainly since the 1960s and
the sexual revolution
but even before that the left
recognized that by arousing certain
sexual passions you can deprive people
of their their control over their higher
faculties and you can make them
easier to control i will uh spare you
the full whap performance between cardi
b
and some other musician i guess you're a
musician i guess
uh during during the event but just just
take a listen
to uh to one brief passage
[Music]
um
so you can't even be mad
you can't even be angry if you just look
at this because
i i think you you know i've mentioned
this before i'm not
the most hip guy when it comes to
popular music
you know i'm not i haven't listened to
many
cardi b arias in my life you know i
haven't
haven't tuned into them so this really
is pretty foreign to me
whenever whenever i see this sort of
thing and uh
watching it i i i'm i'm not the sort of
person who is
immune to uh desires of the flesh okay
i'm not i'm not saying
that uh there's no way to interest me
to you know however that does not
interest me
that performance does not arouse me in
the slightest
because it is grotesque it's not
like do you ever wonder
when you when you watch old movies or
you
i don't know pick up a history book or
something about 100 years ago
we joke about it now if a woman showed i
don't know a little
a little leg you know a little uh just
lit you know there's a joke she lifts up
her skirt to show her ankle
men would go crazy because the culture
was so repressed the culture was so
focused on maintaining certain sexual
boundaries
that any time you would transgress it
even a little bit it was it was pretty
sexy
and then over time as as sexual mores
began to be eroded you would require
more and more
to stimulate you sexually so you know
then it became
women would wear even looser clothing or
then it became women would wear bikinis
and then it would be
it became you know even i was watching
some movies from the 90s over the past
few weeks
and even the way that sex was hinted at
there
and this was not that long ago it was
not nearly as grotesque as it is now but
because now we've lost all boundaries
because now we're in a culture that is
saturated by
high-speed internet pornography for one
and then even in the pop culture you get
stuff like whap
because of that we're just kind of
desensitized to it
and so you need more and more and more
to
stimulate you i i suspect this is why
you see
pornography proliferating as it has
you're seeing now
porn getting so uh violent that you you
had under the bush administration
the federal government prosecuting
pornographers because it was so
it was it became so violent sure if you
have a culture where
young boys are exposed to this at a very
young age you're just going to be
desensitized but don't you think
like if if you're finding whap really
arousing to you
hasn't something gone wrong with you if
that's what you need
to stay stimulated don't you think there
might be a problem with that what we are
told
is that uh being able to whap
ourselves all day long is uh somehow the
height of freedom
right this what we are told by liberal
modernity is that cardi b
you know bumping and grinding on a stage
with that other chick
and yelling about her whap that is the
height of liberation
and and empowerment and you know i'm
woman hear me roar
but of course that's not true it you
just look like
prostitutes right there's no there would
be no difference but
if if you were to show that video maybe
10 years ago
people would think it was porn right but
now it's actually mainstream
entertainment that kids can watch they
can't watch
dumbo the elephant on disney plus but
they can watch
wap on on tv is that empowerment
no is that liberty no
that is the opposite actually because
the conservative view of liberty the
classical view of liberty the christian
view of liberty
all of them recognize that liberty and
licentiousness are not only not the same
thing
they're opposites the more you give into
your base
appetites and desires the less free you
will be the man who sins is a slave to
sin
our free government is built for a moral
and religious people it's unfit to any
other kind of people according to john
adams
the left though has made this excellent
little trick this very clever little
trick
where they've conflated those two terms
and now we we get very confused by by
all this sort sort of stuff
shockingly though
whap was not the most uh
wild thing at the grammys this was not
the most controversial thing whatsoever
that honor would have to go to bill burr
the comedian bill burr
who did not jiggle around his whap
thankfully
because that wouldn't have shocked and
offended anybody he
contradicted political correctness he
made jokes
about the overarching liberal framework
that we're all
living under and that they are not going
to so easily forgive
ben who you know is one of the most
famous rapper's ever to cover
whap he will be he's a whapper i guess
he will be talking about cardi b
so definitely go check that out um
also the wait is over candace owens is
premiering her new daily wire show
candace
that's right candace will premiere on
friday march 19th and will be exclusive
to our daily wire members if you're not
already a member head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
find out why the left loves to hate
candace by going to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
we'll be right back with a lot more
bill burr the comedian bill burr made
the biggest splash at the grammys
bill burr contradicted political
correctness take a listen to his uh
introduction to one of the awards
how are you was i the only one who
wanted to kill himself during that piano
solo
um i bought a suit for this i thought it
was going to be on tv i'm such a [ __ ]
i am losing so much money right now all
right shout out to all the rock stars
that i wanted to meet tonight who are
watching at home instead i'm talking to
you don dawkin
all right what i'm old that was my first
concert
all right here are the next categories
all right hey how many uh feminists are
like going nuts
why is this this white male doing all
this latino stuff
it was by far the highlight of of the
night i didn't watch the whole thing i'm
just
assuming it was the only clip i've seen
that
that made me chuckle so bill berwick
said there he says wait a second
this isn't even the grammys you're not
no one's here you're all just zooming in
you idiots what do you do okay well this
is a waste and okay now i gotta read all
these spanish guy names
i bet they're gonna get really angry at
me right and so people people are trying
to
cancel bill burr and call him a racist
and a you know white supremacist and all
that kind of stuff
now if you're not a fan of bill burr
you you might be persuaded by these
kinds of attacks
however if you do follow bill bird all
you will know that
he's married to a black woman he's
obviously not a racist
if a guy married to a black woman can be
a racist then
racism doesn't mean anything anymore
this reminds me of one time
david webb a conservative commentator
was
he was hosting radio and a woman called
in a black
liberal woman called in and they were
disagreeing and she said well you you
only think that david because of your
white privilege
and and david said are you sure about
that yeah i know it's your white
privilege he goes you know i
i think if we were in studio or on tv
right now you might
change your opinion because david webb
is a black man
you you hear this phrase racism white
supremacy
it's just thrown out it just means bad
it's just like throwing spaghetti at the
wall and then
occasionally people get embarrassed by
this sort of thing i think bill birdo
has exactly the right approach
just laugh at this kind of nonsense
laugh at the pc stuff they get so
angry when you laugh at it so first you
have to laugh then you have to be bold
though you have to go out and follow
that up
with action i have a great great example
of what we could do
to to show what we mean university of
wisconsin-madison
the student government the university of
wisconsin-madison famously left-wing
school
has just taken a vote to double the
ethnic studies requirement
for graduates the student government
vote is not really going to matter but
it really
caught my attention because if you can
double the ethnic studies requirement
that means that there is an ethnic
studies requirement
and that is a very bad idea that's
really bad
ethnic studies as we also call this
grievance studies
is a an outgrowth of critical theory
it is a strictly ideological
type of education based on very narrow
leftist ideologies
of the 20th century it
has destroyed in many ways
educate classical liberal education in
this country it has no purpose in the
university it even the people who
developed it
acknowledged this was a different sort
of thing this was activism
disguised as education i detail this in
my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds which is available for
pre-order now but it won't be available
once amazon realizes what the book's
about and kicks it off so if you want to
pre-order it you can pre-order it now
this should not be permitted in the
universities now
the trap that the left left for
conservatives and that conservatives
have fallen into
is that some conservatives give in to
this and say yeah it's great ethnic
studies love that
you know the kind of squishy types but
then even the other conservatives a lot
of them will say well
you know academic freedom we support
we're the true liberals we support all
this kind of crap in the university
we we want total inclusion and you
expand the curriculum but
just don't make me take the class just
don't make me take ethnic studies but
absolutely you can have this poisonous
ideological indoctrination
in the universities totally academic
freedom free speech right
no no william f buckley jr
when he founded the conservative
movement with his book god and man at
yale
subtitled that book the superstitions of
academic freedom
academic freedom he noted in the book is
a hoax
it's not it's not real it is a fraud
that the left is perpetrating on us
to destroy our institutions of education
it is not enough to say hey you have
your ethnic studies courses but
just don't require us to take it no it
should be banned from the university
it's poison
it's not enough to say hey you know
you've got that punch bowl over there
yeah and um you and you want to put some
cyanide in it
okay well but just make sure the cyanide
is only in your part of the punch bowl
okay
so you you're free to put it in but i
just don't
just don't make me drink from that
portion of the punch bowl first of all
it's a punch bowl we're all in it the
university is a university
theoretically it's got a coherence to it
so if you poison part of it you poison
the whole thing
our society is not just
atomized individuals who can all just
live completely on their own and not
have any effect on one another
if we we go back to this example because
it's the clearest
if our society is confused about who a
man is and
what who a woman is then that is a
social problem
we can't live in a society where we all
get to define our own words
where some of us call caitlyn jenner he
and some of us call caitlyn jenner she
that just means we can't communicate
with one another that means we're
speaking different languages
that means that we don't have a society
or certainly not a functioning one
we have to come to terms with certain
things
and agree on certain things and
in this finite world of ours we're going
to include certain ideas we're going to
exclude certain ideas and that's just
the way it is
nowhere is that truer than at the
universities
the the right i think has been very
accommodating
in in the last century certainly on the
cultural matters we've just rolled over
okay but i think even generally speaking
we try to play fair you know you have
that conservatives like well
i respect your point of view and we can
all have these different points of views
and
fair marketplace of ideas and some
students want to take this poisonous
course in universities that's
i respect that right and you know but i
if if you want to go to drag queen story
hour that's
wonderful and you know have uh
transvestites twerking for toddlers at
public public libraries that's
i respect that but just please let us go
to church on sunday oh you're not going
to let us go to church on sunday because
dr fauci said no
okay well whoopsie daisy we'll try again
next time conservatives try to be really
accommodating
you can you can tell my views on this
sort of
accommodation the the left does not the
left does not play fair
and nowhere is this clearer than in
washington post
correction that they just made
washington post you'll recall
reported during the heat of the election
and the election recounts
they had a headline quote trump
pressured a georgia elections
investigator
in a separate call legal experts say
could amount to obstruction
this was to some people the basis
of the the case for impeaching trump
he's it's a power grab he's a tyrant
he's a dictator he's trying to pressure
this georgia secretary of state
this is illegal it's unconstitutional
this was based on a scoop
that trump urged georgia's a lead
elections investigator to find the fraud
in a lengthy december phone call
saying the official would be a national
hero the washington post cited
a single anonymous source who it then
said
confirmed the details of the private
conversation now you'll
you'll note if you have followed
anything about journalism
anonymous sources cannot confirm
there's no confirming anonymous sources
give you something then you have to
confirm it with a real source
they didn't do that they just said yeah
i see trump he's terrible guy
so here's the correction two months
after publication of this story
the georgia secretary of state released
an audio recording of president donald
trump's december phone call
with the state's top elections
investigator the recording revealed that
the post misquoted trump's comments on
the call
based on information provided by a
source trump did not tell the
investigator to find the fraud
or say she would be a national hero if
she did so instead trump urged the
investigator to scrutinize ballots in
fulton county georgia
asserting she would find dishonesty
there he also told her that she had the
most important job in the country right
now
a story about the recording can be found
at this link the headline and text
of this story had been corrected to
remove quotes misattributed to trump
thanks thanks washington post that's
good
first of all no one very very few people
are going to read that correction
conservatives are people who listen to
this
show maybe some others
most people are not even if they were
even if this were
national news all over all the networks
being covered wall-to-wall
wouldn't matter because the
reporting which was really a democratic
hit job already accomplished its goal of
putting the political pressure on trump
swaying the narrative surrounding the
election and giving georgia cover
not to conduct an exhaustive recount
oops do you think the washington post is
going to change
anything about the way that it operates
after this no
doesn't matter they got away with it oh
oops yeah we had to issue a correction
the whole story was bogus
ha ha we won what what incentive does
the washington post have right now
to ever change the way that they do
anything they won't face
no consequences i do not think that
conservatives should act
in any immoral or unjust way but it
would be nice if we grew a spine
it would be nice if we played as tough
as the left does
would be nice if instead of
conservatives constantly finding
themselves in a circular firing squad
where all we ever try to do is just
police what all the other
right wingers are saying and thinking
and doing would be nice if we focused
any of our attention on the left
and maybe had any kind of unity
the left is pretty unified for a group
of sort of squabbling radicals
they're pretty unified when it comes to
political action the right
not so much speaking of presidents by
the way
just in case you were sleeping too
soundly at night i would like to give
you some nightmares
meghan markle the erstwhile duchess of
sussex
is reportedly networking with a top
democratic party leaders
and mulling a bid for the u.s presidency
in 2024 this according to the daily mail
which cites an unnamed
british labour party official
is this true do i believe this
i don't believe generally the things i
read in the papers but given the
sort of given the fact that meghan
markle
got her husband to leave his family his
royal family
move back to america and she's
constantly courting fame
and public favor uh yeah wouldn't be
shocked i don't know stranger things
have happened she believes that biden
who will be 82 in 2024 might not run for
a second term fair enough
uh megan's biographer and longtime
friend
omid scobee has claimed that the actress
quote has her eyes set on the u.s
presidency
first of all why does meghan markle have
a biographer
this is news to me that she i guess the
fact that it's
the guy's a friend of hers would make
sense because she's like hey get me get
me a biography i'm trying to run for
office
on the one hand this seems far-fetched
on another
meghan markle is the voice of a
generation
she is she is the classic
millennial woman millennial person
who would rather pretend to be a
princess
on disney then be an actual princess
she would rather have the appearance of
the thing
right that she would rather have the
perks and the privileges of the thing
rather than the substance of the thing
big divide between
left and right and i think a big marker
of the millennial generation
meghan markle is no less qualified to be
president than aoc
right aoc is a clever politician meghan
markle's a clever politician
aoc doesn't know nothing about nothing
with regard to say history philosophy
geopolitics but neither does the other
one
neither markle nor aoc really know
anything about that sort of stuff
hasn't hampered either of their
political careers and meghan markle is a
politician meghan markle is an
extraordinarily gifted politician meghan
markle nabbed herself a prince
and meghan markle not only nabbed
herself a prince
she convinced him to leave the palaces
the castles the country that his family
symbolizes and move with her
to l.a right i think they're living in
l.a
it's a city that i fled l.a not a not a
great place right now
convinced prince harry to move with her
to california
to do what so that she could like do
voiceovers for disney
there's a great clip of harry begging
some entertainment ceos but
you know you might hire my wife to do
some voice-over work yes
so that she can be an actress that's
pretty powerful political skill
is megan coming up in 2024 maybe
it'd be hard to imagine that kamala
harris who is a really skillful
politician
which i've said from the very beginning
i said early on in 2016 i heard 2020
rather i said
watch out for kamala harris she's a
shark and then it seemed like my
prediction was totally wrong because she
was the first to drop out but i think i
was actually vindicated because
she more than anyone else on that stage
other than joe biden
has been able to amass political power
and frankly maybe more so than joe biden
because
i think very few people believe joe's
actually running anything over there
at the white house
speaking of people who want to be
president but who
are also long shots of being president
poor andrew cuomo
poor andrew cuomo poor
deadly andrew cuomo whose policies
directly led
to the deaths of thousands of elderly
new yorkers
he's really under fire gensake was asked
whether or not he should resign what's
the white house's opinion here's her
answer
does the president believe the governor
should resign the president
believes that every woman who's come
forward there have now been
six i believe who have come forward
deserves to have her voice heard
should be treated with respect and
should be able to tell her story
there also is an independent
investigation that is ongoing of course
in the state
with subpoena power overseen by the
attorney general and he certainly
supports
that moving forward we of course have
watched the news of a number of
lawmakers call for that
but i don't have any additional
announcements from here so
still playing it safe classic biden move
well yeah you've seen a lot of lawmakers
calling for his resignation you know
we're monitoring closely we work what so
they're still holding on for now i have
told you
look it looks like it's difficult for
cuomo to survive this so he might he
might have to finally go
but if anybody is going to survive this
scandal it's going to be andy cuomo that
guy
is a political animal he has been in the
game since he ran his father's governor
campaign in new york at age
23 a lot of people owe him a lot of
favors
it's a very corrupt state and andrew
cuomo knows how to exercise the levers
of power
but a lot of lawmakers are calling for
his resignation it started out it was
just a
few here and there then aoc calls for an
investigation then the
uh leader the leaders of the senate and
the assembly in new york both democrats
call for his
resignation or impeachment says he can't
be governor anymore
then schumer and gillibrand these are
the two senators from new york
they've been there a long time
especially chuck schumer i remember the
night
schumer got elected it was a 98
something like that
you know this guy's been in office for a
long time he's a big power broker he's
the senate
majority leader schumer and gillibrand
say quote
confronting and overcoming the covid
crisis requires sure and steady
leadership
we commend the brave actions of the
individuals who have come forward
with serious allegations of abuse and
misconduct due to the
multiple credible sexual harassment and
misconduct allegations it's clear that
governor cuomo has lost the confidence
of his governing partners and the people
of new york
governor cuomo should resign
brilliant piece of political messaging
classic schumer statement
andrew cuomo should resign because his
policies killed
thousands of new yorkers needlessly
during code because he
handled kovit worse than any other
governor in the entire country
that's why he should be booted from
office he should not be booted from
office because he gave a reporter a hot
dog at a political event
or looked at some staff are funny or who
knows now the allegations are getting a
little bit more serious
but the methodical way in which they
have been trotted out
makes me a little skeptical that the sex
allegations
are really what's doing it i just i just
don't buy it
it's all too politically convenient and
it redounds to the benefit of democrats
for
for cuomo to be booted out for sex sex
you know inappropriate behavior what is
it even what are the allegations
now they're saying he groped someone
that's only the very most recent one
most of them are yeah he looked at me
weird yeah he said something weird
he gave me a hot dog and then the
reporter that he gave the hot dog to
says it didn't bother me at all i
thought it was fine
confronting and overcoming the covid
crisis requires sure
and steady leadership so they're they
get to the covet thing they're like yeah
covet is the point
but we're not booting him because
democrats mishandled kovit no
no what huh no it's because of the
serious allegations
of giving an italian sausage to a
reporter that's a
sandwich you know peppers and onions
that's why
very serious that he's got to be kicked
out no it's obviously because of covid
if he's going to go down let him go down
because of kovid if he goes down for the
the vague sex allegations only cuomo
goes down
if he goes down for covid other people
go down too
other democrats who were involved in
this go down too
maybe it reaches up a little bit higher
than than people think
maybe maybe the
state democratic machine in new york has
a lot of culpability maybe we should
prod into that
the the real threat cuomo faces right
now i don't think is from these howling
politicians he doesn't care less
we couldn't possibly care less what they
think it's from
his ability to actually run the
government there are reports now
who knows how true they are but this
according to the new york post
that members of cuomo's staff have
stopped showing up for work
they're they're not showing up for work
because they're afraid that if they
continue to fight
to the very last with cuomo that will
harm their political careers
so i'm going to take this story at face
value people are saying that the state
capitol building is virtually empty
okay fair enough now how busy has it
been even before this
i don't know people have been working
from home and telecommuting particularly
in new york because coronavirus was bad
there because of cuomo's policies
so how bad is it really
some you know if can cuomo
still command his team
doesn't really matter if he can command
some howling politicians in the assembly
of the senate or schumer
or gillibrand even can he command his
team
if he can he he might be able to survive
and he's a pretty ruthless administrator
before
before we go i have to
mention daylight savings time because
we're talking about
evolution or revolution you know we're
talking about how to conserve things
talk about the catholic church right is
a good model for this actually because
they
the views have developed over time the
church has not contradicted itself the
church can't contradict itself
because on matters of dogma that
is the truth and the truth doesn't just
magically transform overnight
but doctrine has developed fair enough
daylight savings time
speaking of people not showing up to
work daylight savings time
i have long defended daylight savings
time i think it's kind of a fun weird
quirky tradition that we have
uh however i always say that in the fall
when we get an extra hour then in the
spring i don't like it so much
this might be a tradition that we might
try phasing out this is actually how
we're doing it in the country
different states are kind of getting rid
of it or modifying it or slowly phasing
it out
that might be good and i might look more
rested this week if if we had done that
but this is actually a pretty good model
i think for all sorts of policy
doing things gradually trying things out
in different
areas laboratories of democracy
evolution not revolution this is a
conservative way to look at things
that's not what the left wants the left
wants a radical cultural revolution
and they're shocked the only shock they
can feel is when we don't get on board
immediately i'm michael knowles it's the
michael show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the ben
shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more
see you there